[Music]
when I first heard that Silicon Valley
had built the world's first fully
automated burger robot I knew I had to
fly to San Francisco to see it with my
very own eyes not only to taste it but
to go head-to-head in a burger showdown
man versus machine and I bought along
Mythbusters veteran Tory Belleci
to judge whether my years of cooking on
the line would pay off where else but
ground zero of like tech world's it's a
little fitting it's fitting to have a
burger robots right behind us where you
can see the engineers tuning it up
there's no cooks there's no coach the
guys on their containers chef coat
little programmers in my career on
Mythbusters we would always build
machines or robots to serve one purpose
and that was to get whatever experiment
we were doing right off the ground I
mean you know we've seen precision
robots building our cars right but now I
feel like they're moving into your
territory which is more of an art form
exactly cooking is not putting metal
screwing bolts together this machine is
supposed to do everything from scratch
start to finish in like a matter of
minutes they're only like six bucks
yeah there's six dollar burger how do
they do that no robot movie ever made
ended we're like the guy in the robot
walked away happy as friends right right
the robot always turns on me man except
wall-e Oh separate wall-e but most of
the time right it never ends well for
the humans No
tell us how this all started I mean I
heard you use flip burgers for a living
so I grew up in my parents burger
restaurant I I mean I put probably
several tens of thousands of burgers in
my life you know you do that day in and
day out and you're seeing all these
people come through and see how they you
know want different things and you got
these like little opportunities where
you see could make the burger a little
bit better but when you're trying to do
400 burgers in a lunch crush you just
don't have time so while you're there
for Lipton burgers one at a time
thousands and thousands you're like man
I wish there was a robot that would play
this for me so there was sort of like
this you know like there's got to be a
better way feeling right like you know
okay you got a grill right and your prep
table and this is stuff we've been using
for decades end up studying physics and
they've got these labs with this
instrumentation you know up it was it
all kinds of crazy sophisticated stuff
in the thing and then why can't we bring
this up in the kitchen right I started
making some instruments so the helped us
make better food right and that's what
this thing is yes it's all more about
this bad boy right here let's start the
talk the device will take these brioche
rolls it'll slice the buns to order so
instead of using the normal like pre
sliced buns
these aren't exposed to air they're not
drying out and they end up being a
little bit fluffier we've spent sauce
down the milliliter
we've got 15 sauces can even decide
where they goes to the top under the
bottom bun then it starts getting the
rest of the toppings and the device
slices all the topping spores so you
have literally the freshest slice you
can get the cheese we grate that
directly on the bun we have a seasoner
and there are 12 different seasonings
and we can dispense that down to grand -
my favorite part though is the meat so
it grinds 2 chunks of steak to order
there's a wonderful technique that
Heston Blumenthal invented where they
realize that they can take the
extrusions coming out of meat grinder
and keep them all kind of aligned as
opposed to just like to mash it up into
your attics that your teeth could hit
the seams yeah and then we take that we
put that into the griddle the breath
it's pretty cool we cook on the top of
all at the same time there are 11
temperature sensors and a bunch of
algorithms that make sure it's cooking
it correctly and there's your burger
it's like next-level like technical at
the point of like how does it fit in my
mouth yeah it's a really tough job we
got a sample bunch of burgers all the
time like I didn't get this body for how
long
doesn't take a bigger burger and how
many can you pump out in an hour I can
do a burger about every five minutes
from start to finish and so that's
including fresh ground meat and slice
the other thing how's that compared to a
human ah I I think I think we could give
it a shot as far as like a five-minute
time period but it's very impressive
being here talking to you getting to
know the product like try to find out
where the future is with this machine is
helping me figure out whether I'm a
favor of what you're doing at HUD
because as like a knucklehead kid who
had nowhere else to go
I had a lot of discipline by flipping
burgers right and it just turned into a
career the reality is that you and
people like you set the standard you
guys explore new areas the culinary arts
and from there then we figure out how to
make that available to everyone everyone
everywhere do we try one of these
burgers okay so the burger wants you
guys to try right now
it's called creator vs. the world and
it's our homage to the California
classic here we are final product this
is nuts
yeah this is so crazy so it comes split
like this you know it's a good burger
when you see that like sear right this
is where it's all that yeah this this my
yard is there take you ready that's
tomato
Wow hmm what do you think I mean does
this robot burger stand up it's a solid
burger if I were to compare this to any
other like fast casual fast-food burger
it's up there mm-hmm it's just certain
things like it as a chef you look at I
think that the shredded lettuce is a bit
messy as far as seasoning is concerned I
I feel like it needs a little more salt
but the sauce is fantastic this is the
first time I've heard about the whole
vertical yeah steak where the plate in
the ass to do man
he hadn't told us would I be thinking
this is easier to eat right now I think
I think our patty you'd be able to
notice yeah I mean the fact that this
burger is made as technically as it is
right do you think there's anything lost
on it because it's made I'm a burger
romantic you know I have like this whole
thing that like we developed through
time of both being in a restaurant you
feel like it might be lost now that it's
automated yeah throughout our history
and as technology started growing we
were always it was like man versus
machine right right how would you feel
about going head-to-head with the robot
I mean I don't think in all history
I mean maybe like the IBM the deep blue
computer that played chess against a
human in one but I don't think any chef
has ever gone up against a robot to me
Oh a burger can you make a burger in the
same amount of time as the robot and can
you make it as good if not better look
I'm not gonna try to be a sore loser but
I definitely know that blind tasting if
you're tasting it you're gonna be able
to tell it was made by me you're up for
the challenge
I'm way more than that I'm confident are
you victory are you ready for this yeah
moment of truth man versus machine Alva
kai-lan for the burger show the Creator
exact ingredients exact measurements 3 2
1 go so my thing is is that the what's
going to happen that's gonna take the
longest is grinding the beef recipe
calls for five ounces what's good about
the noise behind me is that I can hear
what steps are on and I'm already late
now remember this has to be vertically
ground
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
try to keep the grind up two minutes of
pass and I haven't got the burger going
so I'm kind of nervous
it calls for six point three grams of
seasoning that's three
three minutes have passed the tomatoes
are slice this is great it's like I can
hear my chef yelling at me telling me to
hurry up I'll throw this in there let
that get hot crank it up tomato I have
20 seconds left it's happening it's
crazy the burger over there is done and
I'm still flipping mine over I'm pretty
sure I bread the bread all right let
that go oh [ __ ] the cheese its needs 18
grams how did it go
pickles tomatoes onion lettuce 7 minutes
30 seconds I just finished my burger it
took another machine five minutes I'm
two and a half minutes over damn dude
five minutes is [ __ ] fast bro dude
you did it oh my god the machine's
faster obviously were you surprised by
that I was yeah but to five minutes
after isn't that bad right right okay
just off the bat can you tell like what
what can you tell what's different
there's one little thing that might give
it away but why don't we do this let me
I'm gonna close my eyes and I'm just
gonna take a bite all right
then I'll hand you this now in a say
nine day could be bad
no they're very close I would have to
say the second one
there's a definite char that I'm tasting
right
almost like burnt toast yeah that's
definitely me just to clarify if I've
done this as much times as they put that
thing through testing you'd probably be
I love this dialed yeah so what I'm
hearing is there's a lot of excuses
there wouldn't be a human factor if I
didn't make excuses to view I shouldn't
have I should button the hosted the
burnt button kind of throws that the
flavor profile so just say the robot
wins for the TV I would have to say the
robot for the TV I'm coming back for
round two
[Music]
you
[Music]
what's up burger world's out makai line
of the burger show smash that like
button hit that subscribe button if not
for me for the Segway